hello ladies and gentlemen welcome back
to the channel today we are
investigating some
another forex scam and we're gonna be
getting to the heart of some
fabricated government documents actually
it's a document singular
uh but it's not to get past the likes of
moi okay
not past the likes of mwah now
speaking of moi
let's talk about the beard for a second
right because a lot of you love it
some of you hate it you don't like the
unbridled masculinity you see before you
maybe it makes you feel a little
insecure i don't know
but i want to address it real quick
because i want to make one thing clear
this will not get shaved
until we get a sponsor okay we haven't
had a sponsor
ever on this channel and i thought what
better way to get one
than to set an arbitrary deadline
arbitrary guidelines
just play a little game here okay this
monstrosity
ain't coming off until we get some one
of these internet marketing companies
up in my dms it i don't care who it is
is it manscaped
is it dollar shave club is it one of the
newcomers who wants to
put their flag in the ground of an
up-and-coming hot youtuber i don't know
i don't know who it's gonna be we're
gonna find out but this
isn't coming off and let me just raise
the stakes for you guys for a second
here
i've got a wedding coming up not my
wedding obviously
a wedding that i am in like not
attending but actually in
the party the the groom's party the
bridal not the bridal party is it the
bridal party
the gr whatever i'm with the guy hanging
out with the guy
who's getting married to not to
to be clear to his own anyway anyway
this is not gonna do too well i don't
know how i'm gonna explain this
he's gonna be like hey keep cleaning
that up i'm gonna say no he's going to
say why i'm going to say
dollar shave club hasn't hit me up so
that's the rules i can't shave
until a sponsor hits me up so don't
bother asking because i'm going to tell
you hey
take it up with dollar shave club ask
that ask them why they haven't
shaved my facial hair okay i'm not going
to go to walmart that's coveted city
right i've got to get something
delivered here it's the time
for men's grooming you know door service
companies to step up to the plate
and offer me a check cut me a check now
i'm going to just start this bidding war
obviously it's going to be a hot bidding
war so
i just thought i'd you know you guys
don't know where to start i thought i'd
start it off
at a cool 100k i mean that's just a
suggestion
or best offer i am i i'm open
you know push comes to shove i will take
a complimentary shaving cream
kit that that'd be nice too and maybe
five bucks but
i'll start the bidding word 100k let's
try that first before we
whittle our way down lower expectations
to something realistic
uh and let me also say this if
because i'm not going to say when the
wedding's coming up because it's my
buddy's wedding i don't want to
get him tracked down here but if you
guys
and this these internet companies can
manage to
to get this all cleaned up by the time
the wedding comes
i'll be donating all the proceeds to
charity if not
i'll be grabbing the bag and you know
paying some bills
okay so that's the game don't ask me
again
okay i saw some saw some comments over
there about the beer that's the game
if we're not shaving till the sponsor
comes and if the sponsor comes before
the wedding
which i need to shave before the wedding
hopefully this is not going to be a good
look
um yeah well that's uh
that's going to be all going to charity
so
that's all that's that's my little
statement to you guys right now
all right with that out of the way let's
just jump into this thing right here
today we have a special one guys because
we're diving into a coffeezilla army uh
email here you guys email me a lot i
don't always respond to them but i do
always read them i want that to be clear
and a lot of videos have been made from
your emails
a lot of them are just anonymous emails
so you guys never find out the source
but in this case this person wanted to
be known
um he said he's fine with me telling you
guys and giving him credit so
this is federer gonzalez from buenos
aires but he wanted to know stephen how
do i spot a scam basically
basically is this are these people that
i'm in their telegram group are they a
scam
and so that's what we're looking at
today i'm going to walk you guys through
how
i think about it so when we look at his
email
the guy is confused okay he's saying
this traitor has a broker certificate
is it real is it not real you know he he
just doesn't know
so let's take this piece by piece the
channel the the telegram group we're
talking about
is green pips finder uh already
never heard of it right that's not
necessarily a deal kill breaker but
you want things that you've heard of
before the second thing that's really
sketchy is he sends me
you know this picture of this guy
telling him to to
invest in with a bitcoin wallet okay red
flag i've already told you guys this
okay
don't ever ever invest into a bitcoin
wallet guys it's
you can't get your money back if you pay
with a credit card for example first of
all
don't pay unless you know it's real
obviously you just don't want to run
into a scam no matter what but if you
are going to go into something you think
is a scam
don't ever send something to a bitcoin
wallet
are you joking how are you going to get
your money back you're going to knock it
satoshi nakamoto's door going to be like
hey
hey give me my he's going to laugh at
your face so please that's already red
flag
but then guys i went and i contacted
these people myself because i said i got
to be in this group i got to see what
they're saying
what they're offering to people so i
joined up here we go pulling out the
chat logs
i joined up as ben bernstein and i
messaged their two they have two like
main
people right they've got this lady ruiz
sarah
and they've also got this guy tristan
grant now tristan grant's like
yo i'm just so busy with clients inbox
this this girl
i don't know who these people are i
inbox this other person i'm like yo
i want to invest this guy pointed me to
you guys
and and he said you guys uh you know can
make me money and i just want to find
out what they're telling him
and to find out if they're scam so they
say yeah how much do you want to invest
that's the question they always ask so i
say
let's say five thousand dollars right
this person says
with 5k i tell you it's going to be
life-changing for you
all right red flag right
like you guys should know this by now
but
that's not even ricky levels of
realistic that's that's another level of
unrealistic
so i say whoa what do you mean you know
just playing it dumb
and they say okay let me calculate your
profit on our ongoing promo
which is weird because your profit
should just be whatever they make on
trading
but they're talking about your profit
changing based on the promo and then
they say
normally it would be 25k but because of
an ongoing promo it's going to be 35k
and i'm like okay first of all that's
insane
i was like is that per year if you can
get me from 5k to 35k per year that's
insane already they say
no 72 hours one-time payment of 35 000.
you are expected to believe that these
people can turn 5 000
into 35k in three days
right so obviously a scam
right obviously um it's
i i don't know what it's the equivalent
of for people who don't know anything
about finance i i guess
it's just cra if you know anything about
realistic numbers and finance it's the
most insane thing ever
but if you don't i'm trying to think of
something to liken it to
it's like watching a an aimbot in
uh in in a video game right it's like
watching
a levitation video on on tv
right you don't know how they cheated
but you know that they're cheating based
on what they're saying they're doing
right you might not be able to see it
you might not be able to see the wires
but you're like okay i just know that's
impossible
so it's obviously something's messed up
and so what i think i need to get you
guys to think about is
when somebody gives you an a totally
impossible number and says
these are the returns you should be
expecting don't think
where's the wire if i can't see the wire
it's real
think oh they probably since they're
scammers
hid the wire really well and i should
just assume
it's a scam but honestly that's not even
the most insane thing
that these people come up with because i
told you at the beginning of this that
we're gonna get to the bottom
of a fake government document and i was
not lying to you guys
because these people are have forged
a government document as part of their
scam
this is sort of next level watch this
because as part of their social proof
because these people are nobodies they
told my guy here and maybe this is what
made him think maybe it's legit maybe
it's not maybe it's legit maybe it's not
they showed a financial services
provider license from south africa
like a registered document stamped by
like the government
as part of their scam right they gave
him this thing
and so when i saw this i thought there's
no way this is real
right and sure enough uh it's not real
when you look up that license number and
i encourage all of you whenever you're
handed something like a lice broker's
license number don't just assume it's
real just
look it up it takes like two seconds you
look it up
green pips finder does not show up hey
where are you guys oops uh they're not
showing up
in fact instead it's forex time ltd
shows up who are they well they're sure
not these green
pips finder so these guys have taken a
document we can actually find it on
google images
and photoshopped their name onto that
document they've
fraudulently forged a government
document
look at this look at this boom this is
the fake
this is the original look at the
computer enhance
so those are the things i usually look
for in just evaluating an opportunity
like this
uh so yeah really incredible stuff
really disgusting
and um i hope these people get whatever
justice is coming to them i hope
some fraud detection department gets a
hold of these guys in this telegram
group
tracks them down but in the meantime
don't waste your money on gigantic scams
right
implement some of these practices i've
talked about here check licenses
assume they are not telling the truth
when they give you
these crazy numbers when they tell you
unrealistic things when somebody says
hey i can fly say you're right
so that's all for now i hope you guys
had a good one
and um i'll see you guys next time and
don't forget to smash
like and subscribe thank you
[Music]
[Music]
comes along